welcome to this video I'll play Patsy
here with black from Switzerland
probably so a real Lopez trying for the
absolute mainline playing my trusted she
go anything and I get it at least here
and only don't get into a huge type
pressure because I have played this so
often i allus as a comment i can move
very often why players simply forget
that c2 is hanging and it's just a pawn
blunder however it is not so bad it's
not like why this is lost here anything
just very often that why players stumble
into it this is probably also the case
here okay I can't keep it with Queen B 6
and I will for the moment very often I
can play d 5 at the right moment d 5 e
594 those kind of those kind of things
also a couple with Bishop f6 sometimes
possible let's seem and you prepare
prepare d5 yeah I can take a tune not
sure how good it is this is probably not
not really great
yeah if i take it b 3 mp3 is the problem
right mm probably leading to a trap of
this piece okay i'm going to going to
open up here after ye 5 i'm not quite
quite sure i can also just go back to
the 794 was my original idea now getting
more active pieces better it's not
necessary yeah here we get some get some
traits going I should have a pretty
active position here at the end it looks
there it does not look like it at the
moment but my pieces will become much
more active that's a weird possibly that
we had to move I can just go here and
this is a very favorable porn
transformation and now he's suffering
from a week e5 pawn and I have roots it
to coming
not sure if this was the best but I want
to want to be quick Ian as also I keep
it simple approach good night against
not-so-great bishop how do I play that
with age 5 with g5 rook to see for
Brooke be a drop c6 many I have the more
active rook so I don't want to trade it
Oh check white resign I'd likely take
that guy could have could have tried
Rukia of course this kind of this kind
of thing it's a very uncomfortable
position of course because this Bishop
is really not a good piece something
like this I have those eds h5 it was a
very weird way to play it around here
nothing special is going on really and
can oops I'm sorry he took which which i
think is ok for me nothing special you
have a comp is giving black very slight
advantage but Bishop f5 is a wheel move
look-see for is recommended by the comp
is even stronger interesting news okay
well this I wanted to keep it simple and
just when you move in a way I thought
you must retreat actually because the
capture is clearly wrong I mean this is
already very substantially I minus 1.5
on 1.4 it's silly ating with black is
clearly better i've got all pawns on the
light square so yeah this is very nice
with a dark squared Bishop easy five
pawn this week and he's got badly placed
pieces all around those pieces are all
not very well placed they step on each
other's toes and are not very well
coordinated I have those ideas on the C
file and yeah I'm not sure I played it
optimally but I always kept kept some
advantage i'm pretty sure gif 4s Wow
yeah yeah okay well the the five point
is weak but to do you want to put yet
another pawn on a dark square here g5 is
also strong pointed out by the comp but
I played the the simple the simple way
keeping an edge not as big in a chest
after after g5 probably yeah this is
this is quite strong I get a very
favorable pawn structure transformation
like something like that is obviously
fantastic yeah with with the King coming
here or the night or after he can so I
after chief i became take another teeny
five which has those kind of ideas or 93
which is fantastic also so g5 is sun is
stronger but I always kept a bit of an
edge so I'm okay with this okay thanks
for watching